I just delivered an ethic complaint to
your office because you lied about me
and committ
here I
nevered you're actually super
transphobic and I never space with you
thank you there's so much more and I was
like I just I need to disseminate this
like this it this it's just so bizarre
and and dangerous you have the strength
within yourself to stand up for the
truth and just about the time that you
feel like giving up is exactly the time
that you need to fight back harder all
right happy to be joined today by Chia
reichek who of course runs the account
Libs of Tik Tok and um chai I know that
I'm I'm I am definitely mispronouncing
your name aren't I to start
with it's pronounced haa but whatever
works ha haa so is haa fine so it's from
this Thro it's it's like it's well but
um I'm not a lib I'm not GNA have a
break down if someone done names me so
don't worry okay so and don't take it
personally I infamously I am too stupid
to pronounce almost anyone's name at all
so um now we've uh We've communicated
behind the scenes quite a bit over the
last couple of years it's the first time
uh that you've that we've done any kind
of interview and so I'm I'm interested
to kind of want to talk about things
that are happening obviously right now
but um me interested to go back first to
get a little bit of your background like
how did you you know started of course
with with the account Libs of Tik Tok uh
why did you decide to first open up that
account and what did you what did you
envision it would become I can't imagine
that you thought it'd be as big as it as
it turned out to
be uh no I never envisioned this that's
for sure so I started during Co because
um I couldn't work anymore at my job um
we were locked in our homes basically I
was in California at the time so it was
pretty pretty Draconian we literally did
I did not leave my house for weeks on
end and I was never really into politics
so much and that's when I started
getting interested and paying attention
because we had I there was people making
decisions for us telling us we can't
leave our homes or work and I'm just
like what's going on like so I started I
so I opened a Twitter account then and I
started just uh paying attention reading
app listening to to podcasts and and
watching the news and and reading books
and all that stuff um and then I started
noticing that all of these videos would
go viral on Twitter about covid mainly
so it was like those people singing
about the vaccines I'm sure you remember
those um the dancing nurses uh the
people who were basically idolizing
fouchy um and I thought it was really
funny obviously entertaining so I just
decided to just start sharing those
videos um and I mean I noticed they were
from Tik Tok and I realized they were
Libs so I was just like oh these are you
know Libs of Tik Tok and that that was
it it was that's how it was born just
one day out of the blue and how long did
it take uh how long did it take before
the the account really kind of caught on
and was going viral consistently was it
or was it sort of right away because to
me it feels like it it you just kind of
popped on the scene and were V role
almost immediately is that is that how
quickly it uh it went yeah literally
within a couple months um because I
started sharing other types of content
so while I'm on Tik Tok and I'm trying
to find those funny Co videos I started
seeing these videos of these like
teachers who were talking about uh
grooming their students and telling
toddlers that they could be another
gender um these doctors were bragging
about giving surgeries to young people
who thought they can be the opposite T
and and I was just like this is like
really this is wrong so I I knew I I
wanted to share that I I didn't think at
the time um I felt like Americans
weren't really aware of how bad the
situation had become with the the trans
movement so I started sharing those and
that's really when um it started going
really viral um it took it it took a
couple months it was it was pretty
quickly you said that uh you you back in
Co you couldn't do your job anymore what
was your job
so I was a real estate agent part-time
and then I also worked in an office um
in Brooklyn and both of those were just
shut down and at this point I guess for
a while now you've been full-time
journalist essentially right yeah and th
this I guess it was uh over a year ago
now when you were first doxed by that
was the Washington Post right that doxed
you initially yeah Taylor the renss yeah
what was that like behind behind the
scenes because you you know to go
from many of us myself included of
course have dealt with uh being you know
attacked by by the media but I imagine
it's got it's it's it's a s different
experience when you're
anonymous and then sort of suddenly
that's taken away from you in this
really malicious um doxing attempt so
what was that like for you yeah so not
just as I Anonymous for about a year
doing this but me personally I'm also a
very private person and that's why they
they weren't really able to find
information or photos of me online
because I never shared that um in my
private life I'm very private I don't
share a lot of personal things um and
that's how I grew up and um to suddenly
become uh have my name published in
these massive newspapers it just like it
turned my whole world upside down
because I never wanted this I I mean I
never would have wanted to be famous or
to be um someone who's spoken about in
public or in the media um it's not in my
nature at all and um I will say though
that probably a couple months or weeks
before I was dogs I kind of started
getting the feeling I'm like I think I'm
like making a difference and there are
some big people who are noticing what
I'm doing so it's probably a matter of
time till till someone tries to track
down who I am so I kind of was like
reading when that was going to happen um
and then of course it did it did happen
um and I mean it was the most chaotic
week of my life obviously um I had to go
into hiding um there was also a lot of
uncertainty
like were people going to show up to my
door um were they going to try to come
hurt me um or would they go hurt my
family my parents um what what were they
finds about me online like I I had no
idea what was going to happen so um and
of course of course there was no photos
of me until months later so there was it
was like that constant um like living in
suspense like what what's the first
photo going to be are they going to find
me are they going to find um pictures of
me are they going to follow me reporters
like who knows so it was it was really
scary since that time have you been able
to kind of get back to living a somewhat
normal life or has this totally changed
your life on a day-to-day
basis um I would say I live a pretty
normal life I
I pretty much do this all day every day
247 um I I get recognized sometimes in
public um but I I I don't make a big
deal of it I never I never tell people
who I am until until unless someone
knows or mentions it like I I don't go
around talking about it all the time so
I I try to um I try to live a normal
life and kind of separate um lives of
Tik Tok from my personal life have you
had any negative uh inperson
interactions with anybody anybody that
knows who you are doesn't like you and
yells at you or anything like that
actually not really no yeah it's a it
people think that that it for me it
happens it's happened like not counting
college campuses it's probably happened
three
times uh in my whole career so it's yeah
which I guess which just kind of shows
you that these people are you know
cowards obviously I was gonna say yeah
they're keyword Warriors and especially
I mean you go out like you said college
campuses there I know there's always a
lot of protesting and really hateful
people there who are opposed to any kind
of other opinions um that I I've
actually never spoken on a college
campus um but yeah I think people have
this like notion that you know we we we
go to the store and we're just harassed
always and and we go we live our lives
and we're just harassed constantly by
leftist but the reality is that these
people are
cowards have you uh thought about doing
any college speaking I have yeah I've
gotten um I've been in touch with a
couple different um organizations and
campuses just hasn't worked out yet but
I think um hopefully soon I do plan on
doing that diversify your savings with
physical precious medals while
stockpiling silver in your home safe
with Birch gold group's most popular
special of the year now through December
22nd for every $55,000 you spend with
Birch gold they'll send you a 1o silver
eagle coin for free Tex Walsh to 9898 98
to claim your eligibility now you can
purchase gold and silver and have it
shipped directly to your home or have
Birch Gold's precious metal specialist
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into a tax sheltered Ira in gold for no
money out of pocket and they'll send you
free silver for every $5,000 you
purchase keep it for yourself or give
something with real value as a stocking
stuffer this year just text the keyword
Walsh to 9898 9898 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with a
better Better Business Bureau and
thousands of of happy customers now is
the best time to buy gold from Birch
gold text Walsh to 98 9898 and claim
your eligibility for free silver on
qualifying purchases before December
22nd that's Walsh to 98
9898 I think for
people especially someone on the outside
maybe if they're just becoming familiar
with you and what you do they might be
surprised that you
attract as much vitriol as you do from
the left given that most of what you do
is simply you're taking content other
people have already posted publicly
online and you're sharing it it's it's
already been shared and you're just
saying hey look at this why do you think
the the left views you in particular as
such a threat so there's a few reasons
um number one
obviously they understand and they
realize that their views don't hold up
to scrutiny um and when you're just
sharing it in their own words like this
is what they themselves are doing this
is what they're saying these these are
the beliefs that they hold um you know
without really any commentary or opinion
and they they realize that they sound
insane um and like I said they don't
hold up so it's a really big part to
them um the other thing is I I think um
I think there's this the way that most
kind of like journalists and and
commentators have done things um maybe
up until recently is I feel like they
tried to keep it more polite this is
what I appreciate about you a lot Matt
as well I feel like both of us like we
just don't care what they think of us
like we will just say exactly what we
want and we'll say it as we see it um
we're not afraid to be called names
we're we're not afraid to be trolled or
to troll them and I think that um that
really bothers them a lot because like
like they called you like transf of the
year right you you won transf of the
year I was kind of jealous by the way
but hopefully all went this year and
it's like and what do they want you to
do like they want you to just like shut
down your operation like I'm so sad I'm
going to cry I was called transr of the
year but like no we don't respond like
that like we just hit right back at them
and I think they're they're they're not
so used to that you said uh you know we
don't care what what people say I'll say
for me certainly at this point and for a
while now that that is certainly true of
me that I I quite literally don't care
what anything people say about me at all
well that wasn't always the case for me
I mean I I I think when I first got into
any position of like presenting my ideas
in the public at first getting dog piled
by people and being accused called all
these names that aren't true it's like
it did bother me I think it's I think
it's natural it's it's a natural human
reaction to be bothered when people hate
you um I think
and for me it seems like over time it's
just been this it's just kind of this
numbing effect it just doesn't matter
anymore so have you got are you are you
that numb now to it or did you
immediately jump in and you didn't care
was there any kind of similar process of
having to learn not to care people say
yeah I think for a lot of people there
probably is a process of learning how to
deal with all the hate um I got over it
very very quickly maybe it was unnatural
um I guess I just realized right away
that these people were insane I also
like I said was never really involved in
politics so I didn't I'm like I'm kind
of like an outsider and I just come in
I'm sharing videos and these people are
hating on me and I'm just like like I
don't know what you're doing I don't
care about you I don't care what you say
I know what I'm doing is right and
that's just what keeps me you know um
motivated and what keeps me um what a
what enables me to just continue doing
it without um without thinking of what
the haters are going to say and how
they're going to react do you think
that's the health because this is what
I'm always trying to figure out about
myself is because people always ask me
how do you deal with the how do you deal
with all the hate and I kind of give the
answer I just gave uh but I'm not sure
it's I don't know I don't always know
what to recommend to other people about
well how do they deal with it because I
don't know that simply not caring what
anyone thinks is the healthiest
psychological state for a human being
there's something about it that feels
kind of
unhuman uh but at the same time I don't
know how you function these days if you
do care because that will be used
against you and you'll be easily
manipulated so do you is it how do how
do you what do you what do you say to
people when they ask you a similar
question if they ask for recommendation
like how do they deal with it what do
you tell
them I tell them to ignore it and if
we're being really honest there
obviously are some days that are
difficult and there are times where um
where sometimes it could get to me which
is normal if if that wasn't the case
then I wouldn't be human um so I my
policy generally is to ignore them um if
there's something like especially
egregious then I'll respond to it um or
if it's someone who someone like Taylor
the runs like I'll never care what she
says about me ever will never bother me
and I'm always happy to troll her um and
to and to have back and forth with her
own Twitter um
but yeah I would say just ignore it you
the holidays are here and while you're
out shopping for your kids family and
friends don't forget to shop for your
pets too I know I never do give your dog
the gift of a healthier and happier life
with rough greens naturopathic Dr Dennis
black the founder of Ru greens is uh
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America before I started feeding
my dog rough greens I had no idea that
dog food is dead food it contains very
little nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
mineral minerals probiotics Omega oils
digestive enzymes and antioxidants that
your dog needs you don't have to go out
and buy new dog food just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for our dogs too naturopathic
Dr Dennis black is so confident Ru
greens will improve your dog's health
he's offering my listeners a free jump
start trial bag so your dog can try it
get a free jump start trial bag
delivered straight to your door just a
few business days go to Ru greens.com
mat or call 844 ru700 that's R ufg
greens.com mat or call 844 ru700 today
and when it comes to the things that
might uh if for me even still the thing
if there is anything that could still
bother me a bit it's uh as you say it's
not names or you're a bigot or trans who
cares about that uh but it's when you're
accused of something that just simply
isn't true uh that can still I think if
you're a human being that bothers you
because you value integrity and when you
encounter people who don't have any
Integrity it's it's frustrating even
still no matter how used to it you are
so on on that note you know you've been
blamed uh including recently but many
times over for bomb threats and death
threats and so on to schools and the
hospitals that mutilate kids and all
that um well first of all in in general
how do you respond to the to those sorts
of accusations yeah so I was just going
to bring that up um
because even when they blame us for
things that are just completely not true
right like just malicious lying um it it
doesn't bother you when it starts
getting to the point of of where it's
like you're you're getting blamed for
this just like constantly you expect it
already you know what's going to happen
and and that's kind of what happened
with the bomb threats the first time I
got blamed for bomb threats was over a
year ago about um that was with Boston
Children's Hospital and I remember that
day it was actually the day I met with
Tucker and I was I was with Tucker and I
was really stressed out and it it really
bothered me because I was like I I
obviously bomb threats are horrible
anyone who calls in a bomb threat should
be arrested and charged um and I would
never you know I would never condone any
type of violence um or threat and I was
getting blamed for this threat at a
children's hospital and it was just it
was it was horrible and I was I was
feeling I was feeling very anxious about
it um
and and obviously now looking back I
realized it was just one of their
tactics to try to undermine me right and
and to destroy my credibility um because
if they're able to kind of frame you as
this violent dangerous person who loves
VI vience and bomb threats um then
that's how they could try to like censor
you silence you and cancel you so at
this point um it does not bother me at
all I mean they blame me for bomb
threats probably weekly or multiple
times a week sometimes um and I'm just
like I know what they're doing uh I I
know what their strategy is and it does
not bother me in the least bit I know
that I've never called for violence I
know that I've specifically called uh
for these bomb threats to be
investigated for people to be arrested
so um you know they they can call me
whatever they want they can make up
whatever story they want but at this
point doesn't bother me at all isn't
there also kind of a weird almost
admission that goes on when uh the left
says well you can't talk about this
because that's going to lead to bomb
threats it's it's it's almost like
they're what they are saying is that
this thing is so horrific that if you
you talk about it it will encourage
people to lash out violently even if
you're not encouraging that I've always
found it to be just the the very um the
whole talking point about bomb threats
to me kind of carries with it this
admission of of the horror of what
they're doing for example to children in
these
hospitals yeah and um in general the
whole like stochastic terrorism thing
the whole charge um it just it it it
just makes absolutely no sense um
because they're basically saying you're
only allowed to report or discuss
certain topics that that we approve of
right because if there's if there's
anything if if you're discussing
something um that we don't like then uh
you know there's going to be there's
going to be these threats and then
you're not allowed to talk about it they
basically want to preemptively ban you
from speaking um and I I actually spoke
about this with a journalist at USA
Today and I asked him I said you know
you're G to publish an article about me
how I'm responsible for bomb threats and
uh you know I'm going to get some death
threats after that so is is that your
fault uh and he basically said no and he
was trying to get me to agree to start
putting disclaimers on all my tweets
saying please don't call in a bomb
threat just because I'm posting about
this and I said well will you put a
disclaimer in your article not to send
me death threats just because you're
reporting on me and he said no so I I
found that to be very telling um
and I think I mean obviously no matter
how egregious the content is Bomb Tarts
are bad uh but they like you said like
they're not even talking about the
content they're not talking about what
led to these bomb threats by the way
these bomb threats might not not even be
real I have yet to see I mean I think I
saw one police report total from all
these bomb threats they L me on um we
filed quas there's we haven't gotten
anything yet so uh when I say bomb
threats it's really in like quotes
because we don't even know if they're
real
um but they yeah they they leave out the
context they leave out they leave out
the content and you know what was the
bomb threat in a reaction to uh but but
they they obviously never show that
information well I've got a holiday gift
idea that's sure to make you the hero of
the season now we all know that the
holidays can be a bit hectic the
shopping cooking the never- ending list
of things to do but fear not because
I've discovered a gift that's not just
thoughtful it's downright transformative
it's the gift of genell skincare from
now until Christmas genell's most
popular package has a special discount
just for my listeners at genucell.com
Walsh treat yourself and your loved ones
to the absolute best skin care in the
world those troubling forehead wrinkles
Fine Lines skin redness and yes even a
sagging jawline will disappear right
before your eyes with genus cell's most
popular collection genus cell promises
immediate effects you'll see results in
less than 12 hours guaranteed or your
money back you know
jell sent out a ton of products for the
entire office I can't even put into
words how much better their faces look
because of genus cell everyone now
disgust me a little bit less it's like a
Christmas early Christmas present for me
and you also deserve to look and feel
your best this holiday season so go to
genucell.com Walsh to get this
incredible holiday discount every order
today is instantly upgraded to free
express shipping that's jus.com Walsh
today and that's a very good uh that's a
good thing to note of course we're
saying bombb threats just imagine the
air quotes around it because I I mean I
will not saying this is your view I
don't know if it is or not but I will go
so far as to say that I'm quite sure in
fact that a large number of them are not
coming from uh the right and the reason
that I know that is number one uh the
left has a very wellestablished
propensity for faking these kinds of
things and number two it obviously does
not Advance uh the ca the rights cause
at all so like of course morally calling
it a bomb threat is terrible that's why
you shouldn't do it also if you actually
are on the right and you're concerned
about these things happening to kids
calling in a bomb threat obviously is
not going to do anything but hurt your
cause and so you might you might have
people that are crazy and stupid enough
to do it anyway but um anytime something
is happening on like a general scale you
have to look at like well who does this
benefit and well probably they have
something to do with it if it benefits
them yeah 100% agreed so you know you
seem moving from there talking about you
know these hospitals and what they're
doing to kids you seem to focus like I
do uh on culture issues um trans
ideology being one of the big ones so I
know you mentioned when you first got
into it you were kind of uh a lot of a
lot of the content was about covid
obviously that um we're pretending that
never happened now the co lockdowns but
why why do you focus on uh on these
issues like what trans ideology in
particular why do you think that that's
such an important
issue so first starters um when I first
started out there was not really anyone
talking about it I mean you you were
speaking about it um abig shrier had
written a book about it but it wasn't
really something that was discussed
daily um in conservative news
and I started seeing it from like the
Tik Tok perspective and I was absolutely
horrified I mean I think the shock
factor of how far this actually went and
how damaging it actually is uh that
really propelled me to start focusing on
it a lot and the fact that no one in
America even seemed to know so it was
kind of like a it was a it was a massive
shock to me um and like I said I wasn't
into politics before so this was all new
to me and I was just like I can't
believe this is happening and no one's
talking about about it so I started
talking about that a lot and obviously
now it's National conversation you know
many bills being signed um all over the
country to to protect children um but I
think also if we don't first of all it
is it's dangerous it's it's physically
dangerous um what they're doing to
Children obviously mentally emotionally
they're destroying children um and I
think that when it comes to kids
obviously we need to do everything we
can to protect kids that's something
that everybody agreed on up until a
couple years ago so you know when you're
going to come for children there's going
to be backlash um you're not going to be
able to get away with it so um I I think
a combination of those things uh really
got me to to want to focus on it and
then also the future of our country if
if we don't have if our next generation
is completely messed up they're all just
confused about their identity um they
they're grooming our kids they're
indoctrinating our kids they're teaching
them to hate America to hate themselves
to Hate Everything To Hate whites to
hate the West uh we're not going to have
a future we're not going to have a
country and and that's
scary you point out that it it was only
a few years ago that there were very few
people on the right even talking about
this uh I remember that quite quite
vividly um and then you had those on the
right that if they did talk about it it
was only to say only to say that we
shouldn't talk about it because it's
it's a sideshow distraction and now that
has changed considerably so how do you
how do you assess the state of the
culture War when it comes specifically
to uh trans ideology and the trans issue
do you think that we are would you go
far enough to say that that that we're
winning right now how do you uh score
it I would say we
are more we're winning more than we're
losing um there's so much more work to
do so we're nowhere near done and we're
also it's not stagnant right because the
left keeps making new things up they're
moving the Overton window so we
constantly have to keep up with it so I
think this is going to be
a lifelong um project a lifelong Mission
I don't think I don't think gender
ideology is something that's going to be
completely removed from society I think
it's something that's going to require
constant work um but I am very hopeful
at all the the things we're seeing in
America where there was a bunch of
states banning sex change surgeries for
minors um removing gender ideology from
schools um Banning sexual adult themed
shows and public nudity in front of
children so you know when that happens
I'm obviously very hopeful but um I
there's I mean we're nowhere near done
there's so much more to do what do you
think the left gets out of this stuff
why why are they so dead set on uh trans
LGBT why is it so important to
them I think that they first of all they
hate America um they hate our values
they hate our tradition they hate what
we were founded on um and I I always say
this I don't think that they actually
have a plan for what happens next I
think that they just are so anti the
West that they're going to be anti
anything that is um that is normal anti
anything that is traditional um and
conservative and they they want
destruction and Chaos because that's
what they Thrive off of um and they are
doing that through this whole trans
agenda that's what I think you know
keeping your windshields clean is always
a pain the dirt piles up and washer
fluid just can't get the job done that's
where my friends at windshield wow come
in to save the day windshield wow is an
Innovative windshield cleaning device
that uses two magnetic cleaning paddles
one on the outside and one on the inside
of your car to clean both sides of your
windshield all from the outside all you
do is push around the outside paddle and
the inside follows automatically leaving
your windshield squeaky clean here in
Nashville and many parts of the country
we're starting to get a lot of rain and
with that you get this hazy and dirty
windshield well throw one of these uh in
the back of your car so you can always
have a clean windshield I personally own
a windshield wow and being able to clean
both the front and inside uh window at
the same time is a real GameChanger the
windshield wow applies firm cleaning
pressure and is super thin to get into
those tight dashboard areas what are you
waiting for go to windshield wow.com use
code Walsh should checkout for a special
discount that's windshield wow.com and
use code Walsh you'll often post uh
videos of public school teachers like
waving the rainbow flag and stuff like
that and um with a caption that says
this is an ad for homeschooling or this
is why you should homeschool
uh obviously most people know I'm I'm a
big advocate for homeschooling myself do
you do you think that the public school
system based on everything that you've
seen is it uh is it hopelessly broken is
it
salvageable at all at this
point I don't think so I think it has to
be destroyed and rebuilt from the ground
it's like and and I always say this as
well in all my interviews it is so much
worse than anyone realizes I mean I like
I'm one person I have an account I post
a bunch of posts a day you post about
this staff there are other accounts that
post about it but we're limited we we
can't we can't be sharing every single
thing we come across and I I have like
hundreds of messages from that I
couldn't you know that I was never able
to share from parents across the country
and I obviously do a lot of research
into this topic and it is a thousand
times s worse than anyone even realizes
that it's it's worse than I can ever
even have time to discuss and to and to
post about so I think it has to be
completely destroyed uh speaking of
things that are fundamentally broken Tik
Tok itself you know obviously you Rose
to prominence by showing people what's
happening on Tik Tok and first of all
what why was this such a revelation to
people like why are people still
surprised by what you pull from Tik Tok
given that it's just a massive platform
of the biggest in the world millions of
our kids are on it not my kids but
millions of kids are on it so and and
yet what's happening there seems to
almost be a secret until until uh
someone reports on it outside of that
platform how do you explain that um it's
I think it's it's probably just willful
ignorance um I think they're I think
everyone is very well aware of what Tik
Tok is and what it's doing and um
obviously how I believe it's a it's a
Chinese stop um it's meant to destroy
America to destroy our youth everyone's
aware with their algorithms how they
feed anti-American content uh just last
week they they were um promoting Osama
Bin Laden and they made that Trend uh
where people were justifying 9911 so I
think everyone is very well aware of
what Tik Tok is um but they are choosing
not
to they are choosing to play D and to
not address it how do you I'm sure you
get this question from parents sometimes
I know I get it all the time uh how do
you uh how would you recommend a parent
goes
about you know shielding their kids from
this sort of toxic nonsense that they
get on platforms like uh like Tik
Tok so I don't have children yet so I I
don't I don't know if I feel totally
comfortable giving advice um to parents
but if I did have children when do have
children um I would I would not let them
have cell phones or social media until
they're probably in their late teens I
just don't think there's a reason for it
um and social media as we see is
destroying children and what about do do
you think Tik Tok should be
banned yeah
100% what do you say to the
counterarguments to that that it's um
government overreach so on and so
forth I think it got to a point where
it's it's actually it's actually
dangerous um and it will actually save
lives if it's if it's banned besides for
all the security risks obviously I'm not
even getting into that um but but you
know the Chinese have all our data um
but for just for our youth um I think
it's it will actually save lives do you
think going going back to the this
applies to many of the issues but going
going back specifically to trans issue
for a minute um we look at all the kind
of delivery mechanisms for this social
contagion there's the media Hollywood
pop culture you know uh the school
system and then social media do you
think social media is the primary
culprit like if social media didn't
exist would we be looking at the same
would this issue basically not exist I
don't think it wouldn't exist but I
don't think it would be at such a big
scale um I think it probably did exist
before Tik Tok I mean it did exist
before Tik Tok uh it existed it existed
for a while before um before Instagram
really got big and Snapchat I think it
it did exist and I think it it always
will um but I think social media just
makes it worse it also gives I mean
right like it gives
kids well obviously it's a delivery
mechanism for these ideas but it also
gives them this whole sort of world uh
this universe that they kind of have to
themselves that their parents are not
aware of and don't have access to it's
kind of what I was getting at with the
Tik Tok thing that it's this massive
platform but most adults aren't on it
and so there's this whole kind of
culture uh on Tik Tok that kids are
participating in and that and that their
parents are completely excluded from
yeah um I think and that's why like when
I have children I I mean who knows
what's going to be in 20 years but I
would not allow them to have social
media um and I do think though that even
without it the left and these these
groomers and activists they're
so they're so vile that they'll find a
way
and I mean just look at the schools for
example but the stuff I'm posting about
has been in schools for a long time it's
just nobody knew because they didn't
have thick to they're always going to
come after our children um they're
always going to have this agenda
and even in schools they they are
creating that same environment that you
were just describing where they're like
your parents are not here um we have
your we have your child's attention for
you know however many hours and we can
sort of impart to them whatever message
we want um and so with social media you
have that kind of experience just on a
phone but you also have that experience
in real life our kids are having that
experience when they go to school
sometimes when they go to the doctor um
or any kind of like trust you know what
they call like a trusted adult because
you know these groomers are in in
families um they could be anywhere
that's what I I wrote a book about this
um but um so I think yeah I think it
will always be there and social media is
just another Avenue um and it's
definitely making it worse
well we're uh we're running out of time
but but thanks for talking to us but
also for all the work that you do um as
you know I think you're one of the uh
most important journalists in the
country and have been for for years now
um before you go how can people aside
from Twitter obviously uh how can people
find you and find your
work so we are on Li attik tok.com uh we
have some articles there and we have a
newsletter and then I wrote a kids book
which basically teaches children how to
spot uh red flags from groomer adults
who can try to will try to you know cut
out the parent um and confuse your child
and that can be found on lot
book.com awesome uh K right chick I said
it right that time right yeah there we
go I got it yeah good job thanks a lot
thank you it's a
pleasure